Speaker 1: Speaking of Joe Biden, Joe Biden
has again made the correct decision when it
comes to yet another request from former President
Donald Trump to shield the White House visitor
logs from the days right around the Jan. six,
2021, Trump riots.
Trump wants those to be hidden.
Joe Biden has said no.
Reuters report Biden gives the January 6th
panel access to Trump's White House visitor
logs.
President Joe Biden has rejected former President
Donald Trump's executive privilege claims
and ordered White House visitor logs to be
released to the panel investigating the deadly
Jan. six, 2021 attack, according to a letter
released on Wednesday.
In a letter to the National Archives, Biden's
White House counsel granted congressional
investigators access to the data given the
urgency of their work, probing Trump supporters
violent siege of the Capitol and ordered the
agency to turn over the logs within 15 days,
15 days.
The president has determined meaning Joe Biden,
the president, has determined that an assertion
of executive privilege is not in the best
interests of the United States and therefore
is not justified as to these records and portions
of records.
That's Biden's council counsel, Dana Remus.
Importantly, Biden last year also rejected
Trump's bid to block the U.S. House of Representatives
committee Jan. six committee from accessing
batches of documents from the former president's
time at the White House.
The Associated Press similarly reporting Biden
orders release of Trump White House logs to
Congress.
The committee has sought a trove of data from
the National Archives, including presidential
records that Trump fought to keep private.
The records being released to Congress or
visitor logs showing appointment information
for individuals allowed to enter the White
House on the day of the insurrection.
Now I have a couple thoughts on this.
First of all, as I've said before, just think
about it, you just apply.
Your own sense of reason to this is this is
the behavior of someone with nothing to hide.
And the answer is, of course, no.
Of course no.
The second part of this is, you know, who
visits the White House, who visits a presidents
at the president at the White House is just
like base level public information.
And so aside from whether, generally speaking,
this is the behavior of someone with nothing
to hide or of someone with a guilty conscience.
This is like basic level information that
when you promise to have the most transparent
administration in history, as Donald Trump
did, Trump ran on.
Obama has not been transparent.
I will be transparent.
And then you try to shield just White House
visitor logs.
This is a basic element of transparency.
But there's another issue which is I would
make a bet that there are many visitors to
the White House whose names were never put
into the logs in the first place.
It would be shocking to me if the White House
logs that they are trying to shield are even
complete in terms of representing everybody
that visited Donald Trump at the White House.
And then again, remember last week we learned
about Trump Tower flushing documents and clogging
the toilet.
How do we know that there aren't some of these
that have been flushed or attempted to be
flushed and then fished out of the toilet
by Trump's staff?
None of it makes sense.
And if you think back to 2016, you'll remember
Donald Trump saying about Hillary Clinton.
People who have nothing to hide don't destroy
evidence to keep it from being publicly archived
as required under federal law.
That's what Trump said about Hillary.
He said Hillary's behavior with documents
is disqualifying to her as president.
Look at what Trump has done, ripping up documents,
incinerating documents, flushing documents,
begging Joe Biden to hide documents.
But he said Hillary is the one that we can't
trust.
Of course, it doesn't make any sense.
So this is about the release of documents
to the January 6th Committee, not to the public,
whether those documents will be made public
by being leaked or who knows if and when they
are given to the Jan. six committee.
We just don't know yet, but this is the correct
decision and this is further.
A further indication that this is a guy with
a guilty conscience who doesn't want us to
know who visited the White House on that day,
now what might be if, if the logs are complete?
What might they reveal, they might reveal
that members of right wing militia groups
visited the White House?
They might reveal that individual members
of Congress who were in contact with rioters
also visited the White House.
We just don't know.
We don't know, and that's why the records
need to be released.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram.
Find us on Instagram at David Pakman show
and we'll be back right after this